la otan se enfrenta a su mayor amenaza
militar en décadas y en consecuencia
aumenta sus efectivos de defensa y
refuerza su frente oriental el año
pasado la alianza desplegó cuatro
unidades de batalla en estonia letonia
lituania y polonia cada grupo está
conformado por cerca de 1000 soldados de
distintas nacionalidades listos para
entrar en combate ahora la otan moviliza
cuatro nuevos batallones de estas
características en eslovaquia hungría
rumania y bulgaria con el objetivo de
mantener presencia permanente desde el
mar báltico hasta el negro la alianza
también tiene un mando directo sobre
40.000 tropas conocidas como fuerzas de
reacción de la otan nrf estas unidades
aéreas y navales pueden desplazarse al
frente con muy poco tiempo y empezaron a
desplegarse en rumanía el mes pasado
además esta operación cuenta con el
refuerzo de 100.000 soldados
estadounidenses basados en europa
principalmente en alemania polonia
italia y reino unido- apoyados por
sofisticados sistemas de defensa aérea
por cientos de aeronaves de guerra